tonight we start with the failures of
the country's top general
you you'd be forgiven if you thought
general mark milley's aim in senior
leadership was to break his own army
his record in office first as army chief
of staff and now as chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
is a dismal roll call of failures he's
never paid a price for them
but the army has and the country has
general milley's record of achievements
such as they are
include episodes of profound blundering
a persistent misunderstanding of the
national interest
and a dangerous willingness to
politicize the army of the united states
to list just a few general milly
presided over the
disastrous rollout of the army combat
fitness test
the acft is a misguided unrealistic
and expensive effort to essentially
compel the entire army to do crossfit
the general ignored numerous voices
within the army warning against the new
test
those voices were vindicated and today
the acft is a now a byword
for leadership myopia general milley
tried to stonewall the army's own report
on its performance in the iraq war
running interference to keep the army's
mistakes from being aired in public
he relented only after public pressure
that never should have been necessary
general milley presided over a historic
recruiting crisis
for the army especially but also for the
armed forces at large
but he did bring back second world war
style uniforms which is a nice reminder
of when our army could win a major war
speaking of winning general milley's
record will likely include
presiding over america's defeat in
afghanistan culminating in the fall of
kabul to the taliban
and a series of massacres thereafter
while our national failures in
afghanistan extend across two decades
it's fair to note that his voice has
been absent from the public square on
this point
you'd expect a general to want to win
general milley was a major force
undermining the constitutional authority
of the president
of the united states during the
insurrectionary summer of 2020
while american cities were literally on
fire in the grip of a violent uprising
with a body count
and pervasive fear milly assumed for
himself the role of preventing the
president
from using his lawful authority to bring
peace and order to our communities he
made it his mission to deny the american
people
the lawful and constitutional aid of
their own armed forces
it was millie who apologized for
appearing with the president following
the now
infamous clearance of lafayette square
despite the fact revealed earlier this
month that the clearance was pre-planned
and not the president's doing
i should not have been there my presence
in that moment
and in that environment created a
perception of the military involved in
domestic politics
as a commissioned uniformed officer it
was a mistake
that i have learned from and i sincerely
hope
we all can learn from it general milley
also defended the slow erratic and
uncertain national guard response to the
january 6th overrunning of the u.s
capitol as
super fast and sprint speed earning the
justified derision of the speaker of the
house
and anyone who bothered to watch
television at the time but who are you
going to believe
the chairman of the joint chiefs or your
own lying eyes
that's the public record of general mark
milley in any organization but the
federal government
any single one of these steps would have
sent him out the door
instead like every other dc creature the
latter leads only upwards so long as you
stay in the good graces of the right
people
don't misunderstand me mark milly isn't
even slightly unusual in his sphere
our armed forces remains a stronghold of
brave patriots
but once you get that first star on
things change
advancement becomes about subjective
politics not empirical outcomes
when your next job and your next
promotion depend on a vote of the united
states senate
their priorities become your own and you
start to resemble a senator
more and more and a general less and
less
so look past marc milley for a moment
look at the disaster of an air force
spending billions on aircraft that still
don't quite work
look at the disaster of the navy's
accident-prone 7th fleet
supposedly our first line of defense
against an aggressive china
look at the men and women responsible
all the generals
all the admirals mark milley is one of
them the crisis of our armed forces
is in fact in the fact that he is
ordinary
there are over 50 books on my reading
list to give our sales always looking
inwardly and being honest with ourselves
in areas that we need to improve i've
read miles seitang
i've read i've read karl marx i've read
lenin that doesn't make me a communist
i'm putting china russia up there that
is not however in conflict with the
acknowledgment that climate change
or infrastructure or education systems
national security has a broad
angle to it this is a group of leaders
who are masters at political climbing
media engagement and spending trillions
in your taxpayer dollars
they even get the praise of one useful
media idiot after another
whose natural inclination is to yes
queen anyone who agrees with their woke
ideology
no matter how obvious it is that they
fail in any measure of success
at their actual job keep in mind
these vaunted leaders haven't won a war
since february 28
1991. this story is as much about the
failure of the united states military as
an institution
as it is about millie the man we get
what the system gives us
and if we don't fight against it it's
what we deserve in this case
a series of aging politicians who can't
win wars we used to recall our generals
from retirement to serve during a time
of war
but now they've become so political they
hang around until they are eventually
pushed out
usually in a swirl of controversy and
years past the mandatory retirement
there's little difference between the
brands of these generals and any other
major brand that has declined in recent
years
desperate to distract you from their own
failure they seize on something else
anything else to turn criticism of their
performance into an act
that indicates racism bigotry guilt or
dishonor
on the part of any critic and that's how
you end up with a person who is more
focused
on perceived domestic issues than on
preparing the american armed forces
to contain to deter and if necessary to
win
a war with china so when you look at
general mark miller usa
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
put on his show of indignation
in the face of entirely justified
civilian oversight as he did a few days
back
in response to sharp congressional
questions on whether the military
has gone woke just know that it's all
for show
i personally find it offensive that we
are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers of being quote woke
or something else because we're studying
some theories that are out there
so what if i told you general milly that
a flag officer of the united states army
addressed the 2020 graduates of the
national defense university
with an affirmation that america is
guilty of centuries of injustice toward
african-americans
that america is afflicted with an
original sin in jamestown 401 years ago
and further that our country features
structural preferences patterns of
mistreatment
and unspoken and unconscious bias would
you say that officer is woke
general milley would you be offended at
the term
would you acknowledge that this officer
parroting the cant straight off the
pages of the 1619 project
is voicing the exact ideology your
congressional questioners alleged
of course i don't have to ask you the
hypothetical those words are yours
that officer is you and this country and
the brave men and women
of every race color and creed who serve
in her defense
deserve better hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else